how's it going good to see you how are
you
i'm doing very well thanks where are you
right now
i am on the west coast of america
vernon's
the west coast of america um you know
i was saying to dan that in north
america
not a lot of people i think are as
interested in the eurovision song
contest
as certainly in europe what's your first
experience with it
uh i remember i remember the year
conchita versed one
for for germany that that was that was
really special
um but being that it's not really
broadcast in north america you know i i
i didn't have a lot of experience with
it at all
until i came onto this film and then i
got to go on a research trip to tel aviv
and actually go to
last year's eurovision and experience it
firsthand
um and so yeah it's been a
steep learning curve since last year
so if you were to enter the contest and
you could have any partner with you
any singer in the world who would you
pick
yeah oh gosh i mean
oh what a question how long do you how
long do we have here
um and i just get to pick one
i mean i love stevie nicks oh yeah
but i might i might also see if sarah
harmer would come with me
so you're getting a canadian girl
i think you'd have to you'd have to pick
the canadian i think that's the only way
we can go with this right
yeah yeah yes i mean that's why i gave
both options
yeah and who's who's winning in a
contest between you will
and and dan in the singing competition
will's a great singer will comes from a
very musical family
he's pretty you know he's he's he's
pretty good
um dan can sing too i don't know if you
remember beauty and the beast
of course well yeah he did a lot of his
you know
i think he did all his own singing um so
i don't know stiff competition there
did you pick up any uh any icelandic
words
anything that you can remember that you
can any phrases that you know
oh my gosh we did this whole scene in
icelandic it was the hardest thing i've
ever done and then it got cut
no because we were so terrible
will and i were like spitting at each
other and we were so like
dialed in and um i'm trying to remember
i mean i think
i don't remember remember anything now
i i tried to look up some words today
and it's honestly like probably the most
difficult thing to even try and
pronounce
it's a very difficult language yes i'm
glad i was
actually just speaking english for most
of it but
um it is it is a tricky one yeah
and finally before we go um you know
we've been in this isolation for over
two months
and a bit now it's hard to even keep
track of the days
um what are the positives that you've
taken out of this
um
i i mean it's it's been a really
great time to reconnect with family
and um you know spend time with my son
and uh
i haven't had a cold and a right that's
a terrible thing to say but when you
have a two-year-old you get sick all the
time and weirdly
i haven't you know we're so isolated
from germs that
strangely we're the healthiest we've
ever been so um that was
unexpected um i don't know there's
i mean there's there's silver linings
that come up every day and i'm having a
hard time thinking of any of them in
this moment
but uh but yeah i think i think it's a
time to
to to slow down it's been for us anyway
to slow down and
reflect on what matters and to try to
take care of
each other and and and think a lot about
other people
think a lot about you know how connected
we are and how much
our actions affect each other and the
the sort of beautiful part of that and
the responsibility